chacun
chant pas cadencés ordre serré nous
voici plongés dans les coulisses de la
préparation de la cérémonie militaire
des cadets de la gendarmerie le
lendemain c'est 60 jeunes clôtureront
leur année de stage
on va leur apprendre d'arriver en au pas
cadencé sur les sur la place d'armes de
se mettre en position
de répondre à tous les ordres que je
vais leur donner en tant que commandant
des troupes donc il est important de
passer du temps et du temps à répéter
pour que ce soit parfait le jour j
chacun alors il y en a ils vont passer
devant tout le monde après il ya le
président qui va parler devant tout le
monde mais sinon chaque peloton et
préparer une cérémonie importante
puisqu'elle se déroulera devant les
autorités mais surtout devant leur
famille donc là on a la sonnerie
tambour c'est stressant parce qu'il faut
obéir aux ordres il faut être vigilant
pendant très longtemps puisqu'il ya des
temps d'attentes
on se met toujours en place un peu avant
donc il faut attendre on est debout
parfois il fait chaud donc c'est
toujours stressant mais face aux
familles on a toujours un petit peu ce
trac qui est toujours un petit problème
pour moi c'est assez stressant parce que
c'est nouveau mais mais c'est très bien
expliqué pour nous donc je pense que ça
va aller on en parle aussi dans nos
foyers dans nos familles pour on raconte
tout ce qui se passe au sein de au sein
des trois stages donc là le fait de
pouvoir leur montrer de leur montrer
tout ce qu'on apprend les marches qu'on
apprend les champs aussi qu'on apprend
on est on est faire je demande tout ça
et on est content on écoute on pourra
leur montrer au sein d'une cérémonie
comme ceci l'occasion aussi de jeter un
coup d'oeil amusé au premier jour de
stage lorsque les cadets n'en étaient
qu'à leurs premiers balbutiements c'est
le jour et la nuit où ils sont arrivés
vierge de toute connaissance et de
compétence militaire et maintenant donc
ils sont des vrais petits soldats prêts
à marcher au pas et obéir aux ordres
faut avoir une très grande cohésion avec
le peloton s'il ya quelqu'un qui fait un
faux pas tous ceux qui sont derrière
font un faux pas donc c'est assez
compliqué donc c'est pour ça on le
travaille énormément mais maintenant ça
va
[Musique]
et le fameux jour est enfin arrivé
lecture dépôt de gerbe minute de silence
ou encore des filets tout se passe comme
prévu pour ces jeunes cadets une
cérémonie orchestrée dans les moindres
détails qui fait office de symbole tu as
fait partie des traditions des
traditions qui sont au coeur même de
l'identité militaire de la gendarmerie
et donc c'est la plus belle
reconnaissance au programme remise
d'insignes et de brevets une fierté pour
les cadets et leurs familles c'est très
ému d'avoir ce diplôme parce que ça
montre que j'ai un engagement dans la
gendarmerie pour parce que plus tard je
vais t'en la gendarmerie donc je suis
très fier d'avoir un diplôme en famille
elle est là va m a regardé tout le long
de la cérémonie elle était très fière
beaucoup de photos je suis content parce
qu'on a pu on a pu marcher devant nos
familles on a pu on a pu marcher face à
des autorités face au général et c'était
un grand moment et c'était c'était
émouvant aussi pour nous comme pour les
autorités présentes dans un moment où
les faits qui m'ont dit les jeunes sans
perte de repères et sont toujours à la
recherche de sens dans leur vie on a là
un parfait exemple de jeunes qui
s'engagent et souhaite donner du sens à
l'heure à leur vie de tous les jours et
viennent ici durée grâce à ce dispositif
si ce métier fait pour eux aujourd'hui
s'engager pour son pays s'engager pour
la sécurité de ses concitoyens c'est
noble c'est une source de fierté et
notre présence aujourd'hui c'est une
manière de dire merci à tous ces jeunes
qui sont engagés dans ces dispositifs et
qui vont demain et bien continuer à
travailler au service de notre pays
notre république de voir leurs regards
pendant la cérémonie qui pétillent où on
voit certains qui le 26 septembre
dernier qui était un peu comment dire un
peu inquiet ou un peu dubitatif le se
poser des questions et de le voir
aujourd'hui fière et être en fait des
femmes et des hommes ça n'a pas de prix
une fin de stage qui signe un nouveau
départ pour beaucoup d'entre eux
concours de sous-officier de la
gendarmerie de la police nationale ou
encore de l'administration pénitentiaire
ils sont nombreux à vouloir s'engager
dès fait tout petit je vais d'un agent
de mairie et ce stage cadets m'a
confirmé mon choix professionnels je
vais je vais passer mes études et je
vais je vais prêtons nos concours de
sous-officier pour entrer au sein la
gendarmerie le recrutement de la
prochaine promo de cadets de la
gendarmerie commencera en septembre
prochain objectif 120 cadets en 2022